et donc la stratégie de power corp
reichen premièrement et deuxièmement la
gouvernance de desjardins doit elle être
revue avec nous ils vont à l'air ce soir
pour une réflexion sur ces enjeux de
l'institut sur la gouvernance bonsoir
monsieur al air force ont suffi lyon à
la lumière des récents événements de ce
qu'on a vu des critiques également à
l'endroit de desjardins dans les
derniers jours
est ce qu'on doit repenser la
gouvernance chez desjardins je pense
qu'on en dira certainement qu'il faut
revoir cependant j'ai entendu beaucoup
de gens dire qu'on devrait aussi divisé
les fonctions de président de conseil et
de président de la société qui commit
qui cumulés par monsieur corniche et
korbi bon je suis en désaccord avec ça
en fait parce qu'il ya une particularité
ou au mouvement desjardins c'est que le
président est élu par un collège
électoral n'existe pas ailleurs cette
légitimité est un art m être un
président élu et je pense que justifie
le fait qu on combine dans ce cas là les
deux postes merlas un collège électoral
qui représente les membres tous les
membres et les membres collège de 350
personnes qui se réunit qui élit est
elle-même ses personnages sont choisies
elles mêmes dans leur propre région donc
c'est un représentation c'est un
processus démocratique assez unique
qu'on a pas bien ma dans les banques ou
ailleurs et donc ça donne une légitimité
quitterait 17 d'entacher au président du
mouvement
par ailleurs la composition du conseil
je pense mérite d'être vu lé fait que
vous savez d'un grand nombre de
représentants de caisses au fait de deux
présidents de conseils de caisse de
directeur général
les acteurs gino de caisse et il me
semble que dans l'évolution de
desjardins son ou sa présence hors
québec que il intéressant d'avoir plus
de membres indépendants
ils ont en fait ajouté deux membres
indépendants au mois d'avril dernier
mais ces deux membres sur 20 il pourrait
y avoir plus sur deux membres
indépendants et représente a peut-être
des façades de jardin qui ne sont pas
représentés par des gens qui sont
président au directeur général de la
caisse populaire tout de même daniel
payés qui s'était présenté contre
monsieur qu'hormis en 2016 pour diriger
le mouvement desjardins disait cette
semaine
monsieur cormier devrait quand même
répondre à des instances
ils se répondent ils s'auto répondait et
il est ce qui devrait pas y avoir une
fonction où ont eu lieu où monsieur
corps me répondent davantage son action
par rapport à ce qui se passe
présentement je présume qu'il
normalement ils devraient en répondre au
conseil d'administration
mais le président oui mais ça n'empêche
pas de pose énormément de questions
d'accord vous président du conseil a
besoin de conseils qui est mise en cause
dans une situation répond il ya un an
nombre de commissions à cette commission
sur l gestion des risques mouvement
desjardins donc de poser beaucoup de
questions auxquelles ils auraient à
répondre je pense que dans la mesure il
serait possiblement élu par acclamation
parce que peu d'autres candidats étant
donné la tradition de faire deux mandats
je pense qu' il serait intéressant de
d'avoir comme un vote de confiance cette
année pour vous
pour le président du mouvement un vote
de confiance
c'est à dire comment on fait des partis
politiques là où on dit voilà il n'y a
pas d'autre candidat mais on veut voici
le président dans ce cas là le chef du
parti encore la confiance des membres
serait intéressant de confession c'est à
dire pour insulte à des jardins je
regardais sont pas changer la
constitution de desjardins pour inclure
une telle consultation
donc une proposition de vote de
confiance qui pourrait se tenir au
moment de l'assemblée au mois de mars en
bi annuelle du 8 mars
parfait on verra ce serait retenu
j'amène sur power corporation
que fait power corp prochaine quelle est
la stratégie aujourd'hui de voir les
deux des marais se retirer de la
direction est de réunir l'entreprise en
une seule la financière power
l'intérieur je pense qu'une évolution
normale pour part
dans le temps les deux frères démarré on
peut éliminer le statut de conglomérat
de power et à grande partie des
activités de la société par heure
étaient dans la société financière
essentiellement de sociétés de services
financiers dont il y avait maintenant
deux sociétés en bourse deux conseillers
d'administration beaucoup de
complications alors que 74 % de la
valeur de départ provenaient de la
société financière
je pense c'était inévitable qu'on y
arrive un moment ou un autre
je pense vraiment été choisi en même
temps que la pendule la prise de la
retraite par les deux présidents est
donc un seul président à une seule
société en bourse ont un seul conseil
d'installation il ya une erreur
d'économies dans cette partie là est ce
qu'il y a un lien avec le fait que par
heure à ces sorties des médias la presse
le groupe capital médias est ce que le
fait qu'il y a plus vraiment de médias
dans ces activités nous amène justement
à cette restructuration sans doute il a
fallu qu'ils règlent les questions aux
leurs avant de faire cette fusion
seraient extrêmement difficiles je pense
qu'ils avaient donc un plan en ce sens
soit jusque une évolution normale
il y avait un plan d'eau de longue
haleine pour en arriver à cette
situation annoncé aujourd'hui
cela dit c'est une société très fermée
ainsi une société ouverte en bourse mais
c'est une société très fermé par
compression ne parle pas aux médias
n'accepte jamais nous demande d'entrevue
on a demandé des entrevues en dur on se
dit qu'on était trop occupé aujourd'hui
c'est dans ces dans le climat de cette
entreprise là que de fonctionner comme
ça moi je pense que l'information
nécessaire utile et est largement
disponible le jeu je ne vois pas en quoi
il serait
qu'est-ce qu'ils ajouteraient à ce que
l'on comprend déjà ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas en quoi ils
parlent entre eux estiment que ce n'est
pas très utile d'aller ajouté vers balma
ce qui leur semble clair dans la sq
étaient publiés par la société
aujourd'hui je suis pas d'accord avec
vous j'aimerais les entend on en a une
mission
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse ce
soit réussi à l'air ambiant c'est bien
et on surveille bien sûr des jardins
bien sûr qui doit confirmer dans les
prochaines heures ou les prochaines
minutes la réélection de monsieur
cormier
merci beaucoup lui faire plaisir